if you turn on the evening news in
afghanistan this is the face that will
greet you
sonia niazi has presented on tv many
times before but she says never like
this
a presenter must feel totally calm and
relaxed during the news to convey the
truth to the people but today for the
first time i experienced a moment where
i had to present my program wearing a
mask and i wasn't feeling good at all
last week taliban officials ordered all
women to cover their full bodies when
outside the home
then days later they said that applies
to women on tv as well
this decree is unpredictable for all
female presenters because islam has not
commanded us to cover our faces every
islamic scholar and political figure has
opposed this decree
forcing women to cover their faces is a
return to a signature policy of the
taliban's past hardline rule
the taliban said female presenters could
wear a medical mask instead
regardless sonja says she feels trapped
if such decrees are issued and imposed
on women then women across afghanistan
will be eliminated as we see now that
women are being gradually eliminated
if women don't comply they or their male
guardians could get fired from their
jobs or imprisoned
taliban leaders had promised to respect
women's and girls rights when they
retook control of afghanistan last
august
but rights groups have voiced concerns
about the growing crackdown including
limiting girls education
and now the female face is the latest
target
wiped from afghan tv screens
leah harding al jazeera